I'm so happy you're here how have you
been I'm good I'm here I cannot be here
so the fact that I am means that I am
unbelievably well I'm appreciative I'm
thankful all the above I have nothing to
complain about it all nothing when the
accident happened
oh my gosh I'm not gonna get to see
Kelly Clarkson Monday so first time I
know but it's okay we're here okay I
knew you would care no but your pal
Dwayne Johnson he did us a favor though
was solid because y'all weren't really
close friends and he actually came and
he represented you on yeah yeah he did
me a big favor man and you know what it
was without me even asking he said keV I
know you had some stuff to do you had
stuff on your plate this is when you get
to see how close your brother actually
is I'm a stand-in and I make sure that I
can do what I can while you're in your
time of need
he's a he's a he's a good guy like
people to understand our friendship is
actually 100% real and authentic so look
thrilled you have to do the things that
he did for me it was it was it was it
was touching it was it was a
heartwarming moment but I didn't tell
him you know at the time I was like you
better do it because you have a chance
you have a choice do I would do it for
you do it no I wouldn't I wouldn't do it
for tape of him you know talking about
you you hadn't actually planned on being
here you're a baby brother Kevin Hart he
was supposed to be here but he was in a
car beeps go so everything's good with
him now though right
everything is good I spoke with Kevin
and you know what these things happen in
life and thankfully he was strapped in
nicely to his car seat so I think
listen I'm only kidding I spoke to the
pediatrician and he he's doing very well
he's bummed he couldn't be here as you
know I will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my youtube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this